what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so there's like two kinds of comic books
in the world right like comic books that
are good and then there's comics that
are like the best thing coming out of DC
rebirth and super Sons is one of those
god I love this story so much super Sons
is so fun because it's just like this
question that was asked what if we
created a story where we have a couple
of like kids with superpowers just
goofing off yeah man let's write that
story
what are we gonna call it super Suns so
the cool thing about this is remember a
supersized focuses heavily on Damian
Wayne the biological stone of Bruce
Wayne and Jonathan Kent the biological
son of Superman and it's cool because
over the course of their publication
history we see Superman and Batman
friends we've seen them enemies we've
seen them in almost every scenario in
terms of how friends relate to each
other and so it makes sense that if the
two of them were gonna have sons their
sons would follow the exact same path
and that's the cool thing about this
because while the writing's better than
it was back in the 1940s and 1950s and
60s in a lot of different ways what you
guys are reading right now is basically
what we saw in the early stories way
back in you know before crisis on
Infinite Earths with Batman and Superman
we saw some bickering but for the most
part they always got along again this
story comes from the aftermath of the
first super Sons video we did which
basically saw them taking on Kid Amazo
which was a guy who basically began to
going through and duplicating the powers
of other heroes and then using them with
the intention of world domination now of
course it was a little kid and it was
largely just Superman and Batman
abilities and powers that were being
copied and that was really about it but
in this instance because of the fact
that Damian Wayne had basically grabbed
Jonathan Kent and took him on the
adventure when it was all said and done
they were both grounded because they're
both kids it may both basically snuck
out this is the immediate aftermath to
all that in the sense of Damian Wayne is
basically grounded now the other half of
this is that so was Jonathan Kent but
he's grounded away from being able to
use his powers now I'll be honest with
you guys
Jonathan Kent is like my favorite
character in DC right now he is
hilarious like I absolutely love his
whole thing because he's so young and
vibrant and like brings a fresh
perspective to comics and that's the
cool thing about him in in DC is because
for a lot of teenagers they went through
the same thing that he did right like
you go through here you look at this
hole Jonathan Kent thing and a lot of
teenagers went through the same
situation I mean remember
you know he's basically in his preteen
years he's not quite a teenager yet but
he's approaching that point in his life
when he wants independence when he wants
to be able to go out and form his own
little niche in the world now he's not
experienced enough he doesn't have the
wherewithal to know the kind of dangers
that are out there but that's the
give-and-take that comes with being a
teenager it's you basically battling
against your parents and so in this case
of Jonathan Kent the biggest issue that
he has is that Lois Lane and Superman
are wanting to move back to Metropolis
now remember in DC rebirth when it came
to Action Comics and the Superman comics
basically two stories both detailing the
life of Superman and as his supporting
characters while they were telling two
different events the common theme
between Action Comics and Superman is at
a dealt with the idea of wrapping up all
loose ends
adèle with the idea of removing the new
52 Lois Lane it dealt with the idea of
removing the new 52 Superman and taking
classic Lois Lane and classic Superman
and putting them in their place and so
what this is basically happened what has
really come - at the time this story is
being written and especially when it
comes to Superman comics is that it
basically focuses on this idea that they
are now in their positions are now in
their roles and DC's taking the next
logical step which is to move them to
Metropolis the problem with this is like
any kid in that scenario Jonathan
doesn't like change now that's a common
thread when it comes to like just human
beings in general quite like we get used
to things being a certain way we get
accustomed to things being a certain way
and we don't like it when they change
and so in this instance Jonathan knows
the life that he lives he knows the
friends that he has he knows the
environment of Hamilton County he does
not want to move away from that lose the
life that he's built on the auspices
that he has to go move forward move to
Metropolis and start a life of new the
other half of this is that again he's
growing into becoming this angsty kid
challenging barriers and so because of
the fact that he'd been grounded from
using his powers he lashes out and
simply saying well you guys just want to
take everything that I love and care
about any guys want to move me to a town
that I don't know anything about hiding
me away from the world it's all this
frustration all this irritation all this
young angst eNOS just coming to bear and
him just lashing out into the world and
so because of this because of the fact
that he looks at his current predicament
has basically being a byproduct of
Damian Wayne grabbing him and then
taking him into this conflict against
Amazo he does what any young kid that
doesn't really know what's going on
exactly what they would do and he just
goes after Damien way now this is cool
because this is really kind of like this
tone down comedic but still somewhat
having ties to the battles of Superman
and Batman now of course much like the
Batman Superman stories this follows the
exact same way in the sense they
basically fight one another but it's a
fight to a stalemate now in truth this
is all just about inexperience I mean
Damian Wayne is very very capable in
what he can do but Jonathan Kent is not
but what Jonathan Kent lacks an
experience he makes up for in durability
and speed and strength so on and so
forth and so again what what is up
happening here is with the two of them
trying to be the crap out of one another
and not doing a very good job the whole
conflict is suddenly stalked by Alfred
Alfred basically walks enemies like what
in the world is going on here now of
course this leads to Damian Wayne having
this genius idea of crawling into a
hatch this basically in the wall there's
no other way to say it basically in the
anus of the giant dinosaur inside the
Batcave and of course Alfred Kazin
Mountain tells them to get out of that
thing now the cool thing about this is
Alfred basically hits back home at all
the really the progression of Superman
and Batman and that's really where the
meat and potatoes of the discussion in
this video really resides here when it
comes to Batman is Superman and we've
talked about this a million times before
back when DC first made them there was
no shared universe
you just had Batman stories you had
Superman stories and that was it they
never crossed over they never met there
was really no reason to
it wasn't until Superman issue number 75
the Batman is Superman met one another
and when they did it opened up this
whole new world because fans of Batman
and fans of Superman were like oh my god
they're meeting each other and it was
like the coolest thing ever because that
gave rise to stories if they're friends
then what would happen if they team up
what kind of stories could we get after
that that's exactly what DC started
doing all the world's finest stories
things like that the crossovers that
happen later on down the line the idea
here is that Alfred really makes the
case that over the years the two of them
have fought quite a bit they really just
lashed out at each other time and time
again but that's because it took time
for them to trust one another it's her
time for that friendship to fully
blossom it took time for a Batman to say
there's like two people in this world
that I trust ones Alfred and one
Superman there have been instances over
the course of their publication history
when that trust has been questioned in a
multitude of different ways Tower of
Babel is probably one of the first
stories you're thinking about
right now when Batman's database on how
to defeat each member of the Justice
League was thrown into the limelight
when Ra's al Ghul's stole that
information and used it against the
Justice League Batman basically had to
stand before the league and say Ra's al
Ghul Gotha got that information because
I assembled it and put it in the Batcave
in case any of you guys went crazy I
didn't trust you enough to believe that
you would stay sane I believed that if
you guys went nuts there'd have to be a
way to take you down that in and of
itself is not a bad thing the fact that
he hid it from the Justice League is
what made them question his loyalties
but again this really brings him to the
sharp relief the whole Batman Superman
fight and different things like that now
to be honest with you guys I never
bought into the idea that that Batman
could beat Superman not a chance
it's Superman the guy was pulling
planets out of a dying galaxy just
because DC wanted to show that he had
nothing else to do that was like the
first few panels of a story and then the
actual story happened I mean sure you
know there's been stories were Batman
beat Superman but like if we sat down
for a second and we were like I mean who
would really win that fight would be one
page long and it would be Batman saying
something to piss Superman off and
Superman would grab Batman and throw him
into the Sun or maybe he doesn't throw
him into the Sun so maybe Superman takes
him all the way out to the edge of the
explored universe drops him off and then
comes back to earth hey Batman
just like paddle really hard maybe we'll
make it back in like five hundred
million years I have no idea seriously
let's just say this Batman cannot beat
Superman
mr. Sunday movies had an amazing video
where he's like Superman could just like
kick his head off or like break his neck
or use heat vision to heat his face up
and then make his make his brain
overheat anyway that whole issue aside
the funny thing about this is that when
it comes to Jonathan in terms of how he
relates to his current situation the
idea is that Superman really sits down
and says okay maybe we were wrong for
keeping your powers in check maybe we
were wrong for basically kind of
hindering this ability because remember
the Superman's moral compass derives
from a combination of what he learned
from the Kent's but also the idea that
he had to come to grips with his powers
how is he going to use those powers and
that's how it is for Jonathan Kent
despite Lois and Superman trying to
treat her son like he's a normal kid
he's not a normal kid he's a kid with
incredible abilities and so if they're
going to raise him to become a
productive member of society
his powers have to be a part of that
they have to be part of that equation
and so that's what this turns into it
really turns into Superman basically
saying okay I got
pitch this to Louis I got to get my wife
to agree what is basically simply saying
Jonathan is going to forge his own path
in the world this also seems to him that
the idea that Jonathan will be inducted
into the Teen Titans now of course this
came out before the Teen Titans issue of
the whole thing with Jonathan and Damian
and so on and so forth but it's a cool
little one-shot it's a fun little story
just this idea that Jonathan is really
just kind of rolling into his own
stepping out and becoming more of a hero
as opposed to a kid who just kind of
hung around his dad and watched his dad
do some cool things but with that being
said guys we're gonna go ahead and bring
this video to an end if you are new here
two comments explain and make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the Rob cork if you guys enjoyed this
video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]